because it like a real submissive woman
would say I would listen to my man
on that note would you go see your
conditioning feminine because that's
what it sounds like you're feminine
based on conditions that your man does
certain things
and to give a flip example is like me
saying I'm gonna wear a dress and paint
my nails until I meet a girl that makes
me masculine it sounds stupid but then
that's kind of what he's saying it's
like ah I will do this that and other
for my man if he does I feel as though
it's because of um primary and secondary
socialization like when we're taught by
like our family as well as Society what
we need to do in order to maintain or
like have a long lasting thriving
relationship those are the kind of
things that um we look at and especially
like within media and stuff like we see
that like women don't respect men in
media so it's like oh on a subconscious
level that's what we take in and then we
may um regurgitate those sort of actions
without even knowing
that doesn't make you okay though I'm
not saying that it does but I'm just
saying that that's for part and parcel
of Life yeah because we look at our
parents relationship and then we say we
don't want that then you look at social
media and you see that doesn't work
either but then that's what you choose
to emulate but then you want a
successful relationship yeah I've seen a
good example but you ignore it and then
chase the bad one and well I don't
understand how it makes sense
um I feel as though like we Chase bad
things because it's it's thrilling it's
exciting like it it kind of um it's like
an Elixir that sounds awesome
the reason why I'm saying that is
because like it when even going back to
oh sorry even going back to the point
that you made about like baby mamas like
a lot of those examples are extremely
toxic and like a lot of relationships
are very toxic and because we because we
maybe despise our parents because they
had such an amazing relationship and we
can't find that it's like oh settling
for something that's just like you by
and large admitted women love drama
yeah
that proved the point that women are
attracted to the pookies and rabies yeah
they're bad boys because they can't help
even though you say oh we don't like
toxic men but you talk about them 24 7
you open your legs 24 7 like an
automatic door
that's that's the real life
now if women if women if women didn't
like getting cheated on why do they
always pick the guys that can cheat not
because they're cheating themselves well
that doesn't make sense go on
um they're cheating themselves what do
you mean by light is in okay so some
people they only
um get into a relationship because it's
like like back to the conversation that
we were having earlier they're settling
but they're settling because it's just
like oh okay I I've met the standards of
society but I'm still going to do what I
want to do or what
um my heart's desire so they will be
looking at other men speaking to other
men like socializing with other men just
to get that
um that acceptance or acknowledgment
from other people
that still doesn't make sense now you
see what is there what she's trying to
say is you would sell for the nice guy
because let's say you know you couldn't
get the bad boy because let's see let's
say Obviously it goes prime time is from
18 to 25 and let's say you're 29 or 30.
obviously the good guys are not going to
be accessible to you anymore because
their old wife stops so obviously you're
gonna wipe either that nice guy and
you're gonna obviously cheat them cheat
on them because he doesn't really give
you that excitement he doesn't really
you don't really like him but you're
selling them because yes you see him as
a cash machine it's a utility
[Laughter]
time time's running out who will take me
he'll take me
um I'm gonna take a second I'm gonna
Read Super chats
um
okay guys thank you so much for all of
the Super Chat that you have guys have
been given you guys are blowing it up
this show um we've gotten a ton all of
the super chats are going towards new
equipment for the studio um that
includes new camera equipment
um also different types of
um we're gonna start signing Talent soon
and we're gonna start new channels one
of those is going to be Auntie's Channel
but we need money to start it up so a
lot of the super chats are going towards
talent that we're going to be signing
soon okay Joshua um Cintron modern
making modern women take accountability
it's easier just walking into the sun
um Pajero Majestic relationships are 10
physical attraction 90 psychology let's
go Pearl get me through these on through
these through Zoom
um Clifford range they will say anything
to avoid accountability for their
decisions and their actions silly
sausage ish must be must be making more
bread he splashed out for a second Nike
tick
[Laughter]
no comment-ish nothing yeah it sounds
super so send Super Chat so we can give
ish a raise yo let's go people beans um
being sneako has entered the chat
um Mr missing four four if he was my
husband I will consider it dot dot dot
Jesus Billy boy I can't comment members
only I am um that's weird I don't know
why I would do that
um Chris the girls bring up exceptions
because they're trying to win an
argument while everyone else is just
trying to get to the truth they cackle
at their own jokes and make no sense
like useless children our modern
struggles the same old modern women
they're not aware and they don't want to
be I cover many of these topics myself
Chris girl in the yellow only submits to
the authority of Krispy Kreme modern
struggles thank you for the Super Chat
and Mona ammonius
um this might sound bad but he's right
my boy calls them six month girlfriends
the guy is out of her league and he's
just smashing for free zodiac
m256b they feed you lives try telling
women the truth and watch their fur fly
we literally cannot tell you the truth
because of your feelings being King
will it wysium thibet thank you for the
Super Chat silly sausage if a girl has
an issue over restricting Instagram for
a partner out of respect you're a 304
simple you're more worried about your
losing your potential
I'm not going to say that word
um list over a building a future you're
not trustworthy beans what about say
ADHD in a relationship Adam Sutton women
only count boyfriends and full monty for
body count I dated a girl whose count
was two but later later blue 18 once at
a party Jesus beans fix the Discord link
please
um I'll let our team know Alexander Way
Boss Hog I can't believe you scammed me
Yasmine mgtow by Logic stop marrying it
staying with men you don't even like
you're lying and stealing money and
ruining your life life men's lives your
kids lives in society two stop lying
um Pajero Majestic Pearl not pal voice
to the chat beans we need more
Australians on the panel sick and tired
of all these British accents speaking
nonsense um benefit
um Patricia I'm here for Pearl's long
pins
Pajero Majestic hey pal I love your
channel I am a relation counselor and a
coach I'd love to zoom as I'm in
Australia the biggest Flex is a woman
that can do everything herself but
allows a man to do it without her ego
getting in the way project utopian women
get off by temporarily rejecting men
they go get off Forever by gloating over
earnings it's a trap hero that one girl
said guys don't want virgins I've never
heard of a guy saying man I would have
dated her but she's a virgin
okay so I have a question for the panel
what is your ideal partner
and what do you offer your ideal partner
are we good enough
yeah why don't you start with me
um I look for someone I look for someone
with the same values as me I previously
mentioned
um I would want someone with a strong
work ethic for sure that's very
important to me
um and someone intelligent so that when
we marry I feel comfortable submitting
because I trust the judgment
and what do you offer your ideal partner
um I know how to cook I know how to
clean I love children
um I love to Garden as well so I could
make basically we wouldn't have to worry
on a grocery store because like I have
my own grocery store
um I would say my good friend my friends
say that I listen very well and I'm very
supportive of the people I care about
what about you so I look for someone
that's um hardworking ambitious a
go-getter someone that's a family man
um
someone that's you know loving takes
care of me is very supportive and what I
often return is I'm very supportive
um I get my own money
um
I could be a good I'll be a good wife
and you know take care of the kids cook
clean you know I can do it oh I'm good
in the bedroom you know I got the full
package
okay go ahead
um for me
um I love a family man I'm someone
that's very caring supportive someone
that takes his time to understand me
um and also like I can have like very
good conversations with and it's also
ambitious for me
um
I am I know that I'm very opinionated
um so like that can come with a bit of
you know arguments whatever here and
there but like I'm a very like family
orientated person like I love children I
have younger siblings which like
um taking care of them as well as like
um being very driven and motivated but
also you know wanting wanting to have a
family
well first and foremost I look for
honesty
which is not easy
um
I'm
I mean obviously my stage of life things
are slightly different but um
you know in general I'm looking for
somebody to to grow old with
um which is quite you know I think
everybody should be looking for that
um
um
yeah so honestly honesty intelligence
integrity and
um
yeah that's about it really and what do
you offer your ideal partner what do I
offer uh stability protection
um
I think those are you know two of the
most important things and yeah and
you know I'll try to understand them
as much as they'll allow me but I think
that's you know that's a
that's what we tend to do we do try to
understand them and as much as they
allow us to
okay
um I want a best friend someone that
knows how to listen and understand me
communicate a good communicator
um someone that respects their family
and respects others as well
[Music]
yeah just someone that's confident and
that's funny as well and what I offer
I'm very motivating I'm a good listener
I can do all the housework that that's
not a problem
um
yeah just someone that's going to be
like your ride or die as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible